and they played one Knight f3 from cram
it d 5 from Aronian and dior homme creme
egg yeah all right pretty much as
expected we gotta a Queens gambit
declined hear of any sort of Queens
gambit we can try to speculate a bit on
what what line we will get most likely
who might be ahead of our people saying
Stanislav they were watching the
official live stream but forget about
that we're gonna have some fun today I'm
really looking forward to this match I
was thinking last night actually has
there ever been a match word to 2000s
like sort of play each other for an
extended period of time like this no
this is the first match of two players
above this rating playing against each
other this is via premier so to say so
here we can speculate a bit what kind of
opening will get I would bet quite a bit
of mount on the next move being like
this I'm just guessing that ronnian will
stick to his guns and play the classical
Queens gambit declined and then yeah he
don't really buy he doesn't really buy
much else yeah in recent times C we
played this almost exclusively um he
also of course played the sloth before
and also the same East laughs this is
everything everything possible but in
recent times he went for this very
surprise surprise move a few moves have
him come in okay we got three c4 yeah he
said yes he six right okay 93 hmm he 655
86 EMS is too much of a surprise and
then Bishop takes
Queen takes and any move from white did
he play you three already yeah III and
I'm like way back these are all right
yeah so we got the semis laughs after
all it's a slight surprise maybe but
it's of course in ronnians repertoire
I'd like to go quickly through the moves
up to this point to show the various
points where there are any valid
alternatives so we've got a sloppy and
from Nick played 93 and this is of
course the most flexible movie and also
we have some some way the most
aggressive move as it doesn't block in
the bishop on c1 an alternative here
would be III of course just done
protecting the c4 porn and this is also
a line that chronic played quite often
also on the black side aronian also
played this was white so in this some
match will have two players competing
against each other who share many
openings so this position also that we
got after move seven now could have
easily been on the board with the
players on exactly the opposite side so
here also there could be Aronian playing
white and chronic playing right playing
black this is easily easily if possible
so but Aronian didn't take on c4 play d6
the semis laughs after White's main
alternatives are III so III here or
Bishop Bishop to g5 Bishop g5 has of
course the more aggressive option and
said yeah tries to develop the bishop
first and then only then play III can
black
not when I bond here if it takes on see
on seaport yeah this is some good Vinick
variation the yeah the sort to the other
yeah in this case all the way it took to
play this opening its of course very
sharp one of the sharpest lines and in
chess entirely I guess play then usually
proceeds along the lines of e for black
protects the pawn now and then a five
and this is the point here this pin of
the night is of course quite annoying
and the only way for black to avoid
losing pieces to go h6 now and usually
it continues Bishop to h4 g5 and now
white sacrifices this piece here but
we'll get it back due to the pin night
BTW seven and one theory just starts
around here it's a easily imaginable for
a game in this opening to be completely
out of preparation completely played out
of prepared line or something because
there are lines up to move 30 and 40 and
so on but the main problem here is that
yeah black has yeah some problems in
this line it's a very sharp and some
some lines are really on the edge of
being unplayable for black so there's
basically no top player who plays the
but Vinick here anymore with d jelsa
form so we have a few more booze a
comment after 97 why play eight Bishop
d3 yeah then black turn on c4 we should
take c4 and g 6 mg 6 hmm yeah I didn't
see the moves but this is the main line
but yeah this is mostly played just one
thing I would have thought we should be
seven and rook you want yeah okay let's
just quickly finish this this here he
played h6 here instead of the boot
Vinick and this is the main alternative
at this point
and now very important is white captured
on f6 here it is also possible for y to
play there's a page for not capturing
and then we got quite interesting line
here black then takes on c4 c4 and it
looks very similar to the boot Vinick
but here black has the opportunity to
play g5 in a position where why it
hasn't played a 45 yet so we cannot
sacrifice the piece here and expect to
get it back so why needs to drop it back
here in the bishop and then be five and
then we got the so-called enter entire
Moscow variation h6 is a Moscow
variation and this is the so-called n10
time was gone and this is also super
complicated so this is the kind of line
on where it is yeah very unlikely to end
in a draw unless it's a perpetual check
at some point very very sharp stuff but
ok noticeably kramnik avoided dead and
took on f6 he has played this position
this super sharp position with both
colors so he sometimes get this
reputation of being a bit of a boring
player but he plays quite a lot of sharp
lines actually yeah surprised to hear
that but I've actually seen a few very
very very sharp games from cranoch that
took me sorted by surprise leaves play
one I think recently mercury and stuff
so yeah it's a min in recent years like
like since he got out of this world
championship the cycle in Kazan last
year played very sharp stuff so we got
Bishop d3 which is the normal move black
took here g6 I think I guess castles
Bishop g7 and droopy one right yeah good
one that's the most updated move that I
have our let me scroll down a little bit
here yeah rookie one yeah i think i'm
watching the moves as they come in on a
website and actually you're
compatriot arkadyevitch is during
written commentary oh ok ok yeah ok this
is I think siloam unknown yeah a known
position I guess it's not an opening
that I know particularly well but what I
will do now is will stop the the
database and let's add this check
briefly if this has been played or often
this has been played so what about what
about for black the bishop on c8 will
you try to go to out with stuff like b5
and I see by yeah isn't to be seven
later yeah this is some the usual way to
try with black the other way would be to
play a five as usual in this some Queens
gambit declined position this bishop on
see itís the yes so the the problem to
solve if you can know how about yeah if
you if you can solve this this issue
then usually you don't have so much
problems anymore and in general to be
like with the Queen and the bishop on on
g g 7 + f6 and then I rd 70 could
probably play by resume yeah it's very
often also also playable what you need
to be cautious offers some yeah the
development you're very much behind in
development right now White has got all
his pieces out already and black still
yeah has hasn't canceled and he's got
the bishop on c8 so you need to be a bit
cautious about about the timing of those
sin upon advances ok so we have playing
castle by wife bye-bye black efore by
white and e5 by black yeah this is what
I actually wanted to mention usually
black only goes a five once white has
played you for himself the reason is
that in a position where why it hasn't
played if I yet you for of course
what he played this is a pretty logical
move to to gain space yeah but in a
position where wide let's say wouldn't
play for here but would play some let's
say some slow move it doesn't make maybe
so much let's say rook see one just just
for argument's sake if you then go we
five then one problem here is that you
just opened up here this this Bishop
star agonal on c4 I actually should have
looked up before how to to draw those
arrows hold on all button on clay like
this okay okay yeah this diagonal here
you just opened this diagonal on after
playing a five and in this sort of
position where white has a pawn only
three why doesn't really need to resolve
this formation in the center because
there's no threat on deform one could
easily you want to change the arrow
colors all [ __ ] should be read and all
control you yella okay now well I'm glad
to to no one one of those arrows how do
I get them back actually the same I am
oh yeah just hold it over the air I hold
it over arrow and redraw the world yeah
okay so the point is that in this
position White has always the the idea
to to recapture yonder for black isn't
threatening anything in contrast to to
the game here if 45 black is to
threatening on d4 so the situation in
the center will clarify immediately in
this kind of position white can easily
play a couple of other moves and just
keep the center as it is because it's
sometimes a problem for black to open up
the e-file as white on example my mind
is d by the final look to create a path
on over by now d 54 what year this is a
very very valid point and the problem
here black cannot really take here this
looks very very ugly
this very quick and development and also
let's say that that tricks possible oops
I'm not sure the coop where the Queen
should go but let's let's even say for
argument's sake is goes is going to the
aid then this quick development might
allow little tricks already like like
this one for instance right maybe maybe
it's not doing so much but just to
illustrate that white is very quick here
but ok let's let's check the game this
can actually be quite similar a 45 and
in this position now why doesn't have
much choice he just needs to play d5
yeah all those longing or anyone elses
oh yeah d for is just just hanging and
you cannot cannot do much else so I'm
expecting him to play or maybe he has
already played this move well I haven't
seen a lot of heat yet but I think I
thought our broadcast and like he was at
a time a comment yeah and I think normal
would be something like Knight b6 then
attacking this Bishop we should be three
and then something like Bishop g4 I
haven't looked up the theory yet because
I'm talking all the time it couldn't
even enter the the moose and chessbase
but i'll i'll check this now i think
this is all it is a still a known
position i remember some game of cards
one against a very strong player I think
this position but I'm not not entirely
sure and he 10 you would think that
white from his position would try to
keep the tension beside her as long as
possible just give black a chance to
fight he takes D and give himself very
nice passed pawn on d5 yeah and the only
thing is wide wouldn't wouldn't I think
white wouldn't want to pawn young on the
default because it it's not going
anywhere even as a bath on yeah I don't
think so but we have I just I just
looked
there are a couple of games indeed and
also some newer games but not the game
of cards maybe by transpositional it was
was a similar similar position so anyway
you have a thought one was I recommend
yeah okay we have a rook da was played
after d5 okay he liked the slide rock
III yeah rookie three yeah okay yeah
this is actually the maneuver that cards
and all the plots are played but i think
it was it was a similar position it
wasn't exactly the same position brooke
the eighth has been played actually and
also rookie three has been played funny
enough so this is yeah this is a little
into my own possession yeah this has
been played yeah in a very important
game actually and it has been played in
the last round hoop game of the European
individual championships for women and
was the decisive game for the title this
was again Valentina go Nina vs Animusic
choke of this past year yeah this is
just a couple of weeks ago like one
month ortho Brown oh yeah white one
white one this game and the championship
yeah but ok I'm not sure it's um yeah
well mosey joke played be five in this
position so it's a and i think if i
remember this game correctly blackheads
really we had lots of problems early so
it's interesting to see what aronian
will come up with to to improve on this
game so you like that in the case of
detainee wife bye-bye taystee yeah yeah
absolutely yet the porn a strong i'll be
bad yeah the this is some what white is
playing for at the moment to get a
strong piece on d5
vs let's say the bishop on g7 the g7
bishop is just a somewhat stupid piece
at the moment laguardia but on Eve I
yeah exactly black young black has the
bishop Pam which is nice in the long run
but the bishop is not doing so much at
the moment and why tries to use yeah his
central advantage he and also this
rookie 3 maneuver is quite quite
interesting yeah we're we're that
rachmaninoff on them a king size when
you thought I don't be three on 83 yet
the idea often of this group maneuvers
is a following let's say black place
move like Knight b6 one in this game by
the way you can also just click on a
square with the with the ship and they
will highlight the square the with
shifting like once I like is if you're
drawing an arrow but just click the
square and you know oh hell right this
way yeah that did work with shifting or
with all sorry okay same thing you do
further on the earth yes okay yeah the
point of this route move is the
following that b6 for instance we should
be three and then a move like Bishop g4
and on Bishop g4 white wants to be ready
to recapture conveniently with the rook
ah that's on the Queen yeah and also
basically yeah getting lots of pressure
on f7 so this rook move is a very nice
multi-purpose move because it also can
be used on in in this session on the D
file trying to use it here so sort of
placing the rook in front of the Queen
which is often a good configuration it's
off much better than the other way
around and I think this rookie 3
maneuver this was also played in that
Carlton game that I have in mind which
was quite similar not identical but
quite similar maybe I should
should look it up somehow so here's a
here's a long time for Kia question if
black does pretty Bishop on g4 Willie
Willie probably have to surrender it if
a point plays h3 doesn't have anywhere
really good to go if white just plain
age three I think um let's let's say
this here and I think black doesn't want
to capture really but retreating it is
also not good which somehow which
someone tells you that Bishop g4 is not
a good idea as after this move you you
don't have any anything good to play
really you can of course them may be
returned to 2d seven but this doesn't
seem like a huge progress iam what is
the special I work on the n97 yeah it's
quite interesting to see what what is
coming up with this whole variation on
had a very good reputation for black for
for quite a long while but then this
idea of rookie three arm which i think
carlton introduced I'm not not one
hundred percent sure but this somehow
changed the evaluation a bit and now
this has got the reputation of being
yeah somewhat uncomfortable for black
yes you can a month on top okay yeah
he's got the bishop hair so that's
something to play for yes it's something
which might help in the long run but the
problem is a bit of those bishops that
they're both not doing very much and
often you just wish that you could
exchange and offer something to ya to
relieve a bit of the pressure here I'm
not sure this b5 move which was played
in this woman game it was we had some
about four or five weeks ago we can we
can share quickly how that went so much
about that played b5
and then goonie not take on took on c6
takes here and 95 so it's a temporary
peace sec for one move and do I'd Noah
gets a piece back Bishop d7 92 we should
be five Quincy too yeah that's that's
not much fun for black and I you know
that that I like bishops but this this
knight on d5 is more than annoying roop
season relatively then I would like them
to be and I take that night with just
about any better rooks III Queen a6 if
form yeah this looks looks a bit ugly
yeah and I think white white one c4 at
the end we should yeah of Quincy one now
the rook is protected and also the
Knights doing quite some provokes quite
some weakening here yeah I think white
was white was pretty better in this
position yeah this this doesn't look
really like the way to go as like it
seems very weak here in the center so i
don't really expect be five but well you
never know this is a very concrete
variation maybe there's some way to
improve this but it doesn't look fine to
me um also I want to want to add that in
general for this broadcast i'm not using
an engine I'm just yeah we decided we
will try to not you tender the West the
game got super creative and either very
powerful going on yeah
yes someone is asking if this last
stream is sponsored so yeah someone
wants to send me a couple of hundred
euros I'll take them but only half of
that no this is this is just for fun we
was for try to adjust well we're just
trying this out and see how it goes okay
I'm so it's sister Sofia did you did he
play p5 someone mentioned jackie has he
has actually played me five i just it
just came through on the feet that i'm
watching now okay so he's going to go in
for that line and I guess we'll see what
happens yeah okay maybe this is some
there are some concrete points here so
let's check whicli in this game and why
took on c6 and where we can check at
which point there might be alternatives
so what what else is there yeah well
black let's let's go quickly through the
basic possibilities just retaking is out
of the question because of this move
here and the rook drops so black cannot
recapture um if like what else could
like do we could move the night which
looks oops maybe like here but now i can
simply play this maybe I've got
something strongly even but this should
be a should be enough black come
something like this is just over and
okay this is also nothing you would like
to see on your bot so and then really
really black can't take the bishop after
Knight takes Knight fish on takes bishop
this no to move toward 96-95 where I saw
I didn't
oh okay like just retake the vision I
got you okay so I guess this is pretty
much forced take here then 95 looks also
quite quite normal black needs to play
Queen d6 he doesn't have any any
alternatives really we can go here but
this walks right into a fork oh no maybe
Quincy 60 okay this is maybe not so
clear-cut let's quickly check if this
move might be any any alternative oh
well let's see we've got v5 yep DC and
vision and context C or SMN okay and
then we have got exactly this position
so 95 is very logical I was just trying
to figure out that this is the only move
or Queenie 6 it doesn't look great but
I'm not quite sure yet if white can
refute it outright so in what about my
t-bone yeah 97 I can capture c6 here and
cover the rook this way and hear this
why does just sacrificed materially and
it's worse but so this this wouldn't
help much e 6 is a city square but maybe
I'm why just just wrapped the greps and
yeah he did by 90 bar yeah maybe why
just grabs here and after this get the
queen is just a bit silly on e6 yeah
maybe the good thing is if I'm saying
the Queen City only six then maybe
Aronian will play it this is the this is
the usual the usual way [ __ ] for
commentators not to say how this move is
complete rubbish and then he's playing
it and the better players will be here
no quiet yeah okay but I pretty much
expect
26 if I could eat that he did yeah he
did Jeff yep okay yeah well I wondered
one side of the other is still in
preparation here yeah of course they're
boiling they have both deep in
preparation because this is a known
position and the question is well this
position is some already slightly
simplified and the question is if this
maybe yeah there's some likelihood that
this position once is going yet quite
quickly I think because just like dry
yeah they just imagine black and black
has some way to get rid of this knight
on d5 in any way let's say Queenie 60d
play Queenie six right what yeah okay
let's say why do I takes here and then
maybe recaptures hear this okay maybe
you can really go nite c7 now so this is
maybe a useless recapture let's say it
takes with rook let's check this quickly
um if this is an alternative your idea
being Bishop d7 and just packing this
night of the boy yeah and if this
happens black should be completely fine
or whatever what about the Queen's I
thought they were sort of isolating and
bacteria that not enough play for again
for what yeah maybe but never just let's
say just a complete moves here if I play
let's say what should white play in this
position the rook now only three looks a
bit silly it's not doing anything in
regards to this this pin ever what about
the Queen Queen z2 and then work Paul by
roughly three yeah maybe this is an idea
okay let's let's say I play
this should be seven and I'm not
threatening to to win this pawn on d5
you are running one yeah okay they I
grabbed it I grabbed it and you know I
guess what I have to go let's just let's
just imagine this kind of scenario here
and there not necessarily the best moves
but this is this kind of position is
what I was referring to as debt yeah if
I can see it is if we draw I think that
went fine I had do it agrees to draw
very quick yeah just not just the point
if Black gets rid of this year and this
would also free up the bishop as he can
always play you for and then black
doesn't have much of a problem so maybe
this is the point of this Queenie 6 move
that black can recapture here and then
quickly get some play going with them
with Bishop e7 against this knight on d5
this could be an idea so we're up to 70
viewers on the screen right now so
welcome those of you who have some come
in kind of recently you're watching a
live feed myself and Christopher what
we're talking and explaining and
streaming the cranoch Aronian match
which is going on live right now and
this is the first time ever that to 2800
players have played against each other
in an extended match okay if they play
against each other in individual
tournaments but this is just a
one-on-one extended match and we are
pretty at least I'm pretty excited this
and I think they Christoph you are too
and I think the rest of you guys are too
or you wouldn't be here in the morning
we'll see let's talk about it yeah this
might have anything else yeah yeah I
needs to take on d 7 what else is there
yeah what are you gotta gonna be back
right yeah yeah sometimes really always
have to check for tricks but
think there are any here I'll see any I
think tonight is the night squares are
covered for the moment in well yeah I
guess he has to yeah what has such what
has to take I wonder why I didn't he
didn't play the play there's already are
they might have a the movement come
through i'll be there either yeah you
you always have to check a bit a bit the
tactics here because it's not completely
a non-technical disposition now let's
just say black is not threatening to
take the pawn because 97 winter Queen so
you can you could imagine some some
tactical trixia I'm not using a comp so
maybe it's completely ridiculous so
let's just for just for fun look look
quickly at a move like Queen a form the
idea being if black retreats now or puts
the night somewhere where doesn't detect
the Queen let's say here you would play
this and actually win the rook yeah the
Queen covers on window rock yeah yeah
the queen cover c6 the green car on fire
yeah and I think okay black can play
this move here and I think this should
should solve the issue but you can
continue this line let's say c7 for
instance attacking the rook and so on
you can you can calculate a bit
disposition so we're display go now you
you take on c4 next you've got two
points for peace and quite some knight
on d5 not what it most likely the
computer will will laugh but what and
not not co it's not completely
ridiculous to to spend a couple of
minutes and even if it's just recapping
your home preparation if thumb computer
lines but I that are showing up on a
date that I'm looking at for the moves
and
I won't spoil your dream by telling you
what the confidence of the move Queen a
for which is a line that is showing up
yeah its most likely nonsense but it's
giving that at minus minus 14 black
after cleaning or 95 yeah so it's itself
way playable at least him yes that's not
bad but it's giving after after C
taystee 7 is you will advantage for
black like minus point 1 up to okay
sorry I guess the computer is always
liked having the bridge attack yeah just
say I need to see text e7 yeah and he
wants to recapture with the Roca I guess
yeah yep yeah okay that's probably what
we're going to see coming up on the
board although i don't see who's having
been we haven't been relayed yet I mean
what engine is this is this is Houdini
most likely the unit area and it's
giving this is already a slightly
minuscule may be better for black yeah
yep interesting i guess probably just
because of a bishop their butts on yahoo
okay maybe but this position is wide
open also and on the computer should be
pretty reliable in this kind of position
i think so interesting maybe yeah I
cannot believe this isn't from
prominence preparation it was just if it
based on on the on a five-week-old game
they know this stuff so you think that
these players are up on on on the games
that have been played in this position
even though on that from the
championship for a few weeks ago yeah of
course they must letter is they really
do their homework huh yeah they must
know this of course I mean I mean even I
knew this game
I didn't you the exact position I knew
that they played the semi sloth and sort
of stuff and then oh the game of course
but yeah maybe Kramnik is still slightly
surprised i think his main preparation
certainly focused on the the classical
Queens gambit I think not so much on the
on the semis love but still he should
have some idea father in mind the young
yeah of course why doesn't isn't were so
anything not to give this impression i
think it's only um yeah meds for me at
the moment how to see how I'd react to
this some pressure put on on the night
with Bishop e7 I also do have what I was
driving it back the debris yeah I was
just thinking about that if this is this
is an idea first of all you would need
to move the Queen but 22 is the pretty
um it's a pretty um yeah natural move
and yeah just there should be seven this
most of the line we had we had before
and now instead of this rook see one
move or instead of capturing this would
also be pretty much nothing yeah okay
this kind of position why does even
worse I think you might be able to hold
but f-5e for is coming up so you don't
want to have that so just drop this
night back to 33 m yeah you don't want
to do that but not so beautiful on that
phone or what you do yeah maybe need
maybe go into this drawing line I would
certainly prefer this drawing line to
this trying to get something in a
position where black has two bishops
both as two nights
it's always so yeah the love you open
for that I guess okay let's let's let's
put a couple of more moves on the board
Roque ath maybe would be a very natural
move black handsome maybe even though
the chance to infiltrate somewhere here
on d3 or on d to at some point if this
night would ever move and it's hard to
imagine what Y term should try to do
here but I sleep much better buyer yeah
maybe it's not not the end of the world
for white but it's not the kind of
position where you try to win really so
it's not looking good well cramming is
in the thinking box here so he's trying
to come up with something I'm not sure I
think we're still on the position where
he still has to retake his piece so I
don't know he takes the seven most
pretty obvious to me yeah maybe he's
just he's just spending time now to
think about what is finally in the
future yeah maybe but ok am as I said
moves tonight this for you and not
completely ridiculous I would think
about this I at least a bit but the
strange thing is that he's thinking at
all yeah because you may be yeah you
should you should have some preppy em
and worked out before I've see g7 is a
move or not but ok these guys also
cannot prepare everything so you you
basically automatically assume once it
is below move 20 they should know that
stuff but it's not it's not always the
case and also we should mention that in
the event that this does peter out to a
quick draw they will play a rapid game
for the spectators that doesn't count
towards the official match score but you
know people are showing up to see these
guys play the game is a draw twenty five
moves that may I get to really get their
minds work so if this game better become
a quick draw we'll hang out
and some of the rapid match as well
which that way and I'm not sure what the
time controls for that will be but
probably like 25 minutes or half an hour
on each clock or something yeah I think
so this is a good a good idea really
because it can can always happen now
that yeah it's just an unlucky
preparation and the the the position is
completely dead and its really I don't
see a point in continuing for for ages
in a completely boring position you
might as well draw it and then let's
let's play some some action game after
this so this is much better than letting
them play by some sort of room to play
always 60 moves or something in general
i'm in favor of this rule but four shots
for such a match this is as a training
purpose and also a little bit of an
entertainment purpose i think it's
better just to do this with this rapid
game yeah i agree it would be tough to
do that in a large economy you know so
just for just for two people slave 5
asks i just joined so Kramnik is white ?
yes welcome blaze p5 kramnik is white
and we had a semi lot of opening of the
position you see on the board right now
is the current position and Kramnik has
been in the thinking box for a while
here and we're just not sure why because
it seems like he has to retake his piece
on d 7 with pod tasty 7 but maybe you
look at some other stuff and help lift
out his next be moves no very hard for
me to believe that this is not
preparation obviously it is by Aronian
but if i'ma ronnians point of view it's
it's quite clear that this is the
preparation because he went for the
semis slab which he of course played
before but it's maybe a slight surprise
in in this match as he
played the Queens gambit declined so
yeah so steadily the last couple of
tournaments and black doesn't have so
much choice before this and so let's say
the position after the tenth move Bishop
g7 just put this up quickly this is
basically the main position after after
five h6 and white captures and e4 if one
and je form also the normal completely
normal moves so very very likely that
this is some adhesive Rodians prep okay
I wouldn't think this booths came very
quickly this would probably be involved
with their presence at this point but
yeah strange the cranoch is already out
so soon yeah please p5 we were thinking
after 97 Queen takes c6 night takes a
queen takes AAA and black Atari the
Black has already given up a piece on c4
which was his light square Bishop so
it'll have two pieces for the rook and
down upon so that's just not good yeah
this is uh this this variation yeah so
this is just two pieces for a look and
not even upon just out all right or is
that honestly one yeah pawn wise it's
identical but the Met black has 22 minor
pieces to bishops for especially and
also a potential to sink this 1923 night
now time for me to use this cool arrows
again also this might be an idea of
course after you do something about the
rook on the 80 yeah a lot of Proverbs
how do i get these arrows how do i get
rid of me is so this this looks looks
tricky yeah okay i know that i managed
somehow okay at the end he will take on
descent maybe is some calculating a bit
of this night a form move my queen a
form of course not
Queen a phone but I don't see anything
else really yeah yeah we'll take oh it
is I don't know how how these top level
players choose to you know a set use
their time but is it possible that he's
like okay I know I'm going to play pawn
takes d7 but let me explore some other
let me explore what happens in the
position after that and or or or is it
just like oh should they just play the
move and then think later that it you
know I don't know yeah usually am
they're practical enough to just take
and save that time but i'm not sure what
what Kramnik is doing maybe is trying to
remember something a little bit later in
the course of you when's this is um this
is possible that he had this prepared
somehow but forgot it and now tries to
remember how it is continued yeah this
is I think a huge part of modern grand
master chess on the top level is just
remembering you analysis this is yeah
well father all the emulator valve every
day it must be I must be tough keeping
all that in your head yeah just let's
just explore this once again quickly
rook t7 is very logical so does white
have anything entirely different here
the problem is the problem for white I
think that black stang is too safe to
draw the draw of anything even with the
hook on the on the e-file which can
easily switch over to like Age 3 or
something in some positions like if that
bishop or a Nazi eight and such but I
don't know why always feel pretty safe
when my opponent doesn't have a dark
squared bishop and I have my king being
a note on that side with dark for bishop
yeah there won't be any bitching
takes in this game and well romania tax
or uh or white maybe like you fill out
something but it's it's it's really i
have some problems to imagine what what
white would try here in this position to
avoid Bishop d7 and then and just like
liquidating on d5 at least liquidating
to to get them to get a draw so like
sacrificing upon would be ludicrous
right you know just just stacking the
pawn on d5 for the Ponzi for seems like
a crazy idea to be but you know maybe
it's something but then i guess ii for
comes and then for Blackie for comes
then just looks like a mess hmm yeah i
touch I don't think white has some watch
s anything here but maybe maybe I'm too
negative here because I liked with the
bishop so much but I deserve our version
yeah but this is nothing nothing special
really a lot of even top players have a
huge preference for the bishop and the
bishop is just better than the night is
Sir this is no question most is yeah in
most cases it is right what about what
about I nice light there on debris I
think that would that would be better
than average I've got a lot of cases
yeah of course it's just a dependent on
the position but most cases bishop is
usually stronger yeah very often it's
just I guess as long as the pawn
structure on e4 e5 stays the same flax
flax bishop on g7 is it's not doing much
except for protecting the king yeah so
you can say that black has the bishop
pair but one of the bishops is
restricted the one on be sending
together a nice piece but yeah Blake has
some possibilities of
should have a to c 5 this one idea we
also h5 Bishop h6 can be an idea for
instance if Y tries to play rook see one
at some point then the bishop on age six
would be quite annoying and by what I
was just thinking just imagine this
position here and just um lets let's
letz for argument's sake say there
wouldn't be a pawn on c4 okay yeah let's
just take the spawn away and let's say
for this point black is to move just
just an argument gap imagine the bone is
gone and black moves we should be seven
in this position even this is just
nothing for White Rock d3 rock d 8 and
have so much pressure in the center that
white is never better never so very
interesting to see him what you will
come up with besides that even with on
just gone and white up upon for no
reason yeah for temple visually 792
should be seven yeah if it was a the
pawn would be gone in this position and
white smooth white can play rook to e3
and Bishop d7 is not possible because of
Knight f6 check just the technical
reason yeah yeah but it's easily
possible that black would in some if you
would have slightly better pieces like
110 / more or something then this is
even a position which varun's
compensation for porn easily to Bishop
is the 18 in the chat says don't know
why Panik is wasting time here yeah we
don't know why either yeah I don't you
see right now is not the one that's
currently on the board but what we
expect to show up on the board very
shortly and yeah not sure why he's
betting to what time I don't get it I
actually to to to understand this time
management I quickly put up the engine
actually and just try to quickly if
there's any other feasible move and the
engine
Houdini here actually gave night before
as only or 0.6 for black so but but what
kind of move was this this is completely
ridiculous I have never seen a game of
chess where night is good on before
really well ok ok so just to mention the
night is 10 on d 7 in this case so the
night he can't move the night or was a
nice party protects the right now he
can't move the night because it's headed
into the rug yeah but-but-but blackest
the roof is completely idiotic if blitz
place a 5 what are you doing yeah that's
true yeah unit you need to capture on
this end yeah and then return back to d5
it's completely ridiculous so of course
this line is given as clearly clearly
better for black also 10.6 is quite much
so this move is even more ridiculous
than Queen a for which at least I think
married some some minutes let's say you
invest three or four minutes to check
out this is may be possible but then you
should really should really check on d 7
yeah and we'll get this patient group t7
will get this and then yeah then we'll
be interesting well yeah cranoch is the
one of the best players generations up
and gotta give him some credit he
started now so he's doing but this is
very strange very very strange so what
could why do I do here let's let's think
about maybe some some other piece
configurations what I would like to do
is why this of course windows e4 pawn
after all so if I've got the time I
would like to play something along the
lines of let's say Quincy to to get the
Queen out of the D far were crooks III
and then at the end night
me to see for this would be just great
the night on c4 would nice Liam blocks
the sea far let's say b3 later and i'm
just a pawn up black as the bishop a
okay but the problem is i don't see how
you can get to this yeah yeah flag make
moves between that is the problem yeah
now so first move would be queen c2
there should be seven and then yeah this
thing on d5 is sustained and i don't
know what what what white might do here
besides while liquidating what it's
possible is that is maybe thinking a bit
at this position because his sort of
anticipates exactly this year and maybe
maybe thinks okay this is a draw already
so do I have something else what about
let's go back to the position when rugby
seven on port and at Bishop e7 yeah rope
27 and then Quincy to that brings you to
the efficient p 7 what about nine feet
for nod we're sorry might be for what
does not doing there if I think it if I
just take it do you return to 8500 like
what why do you just get the answer I
just gonna take away I was before yeah
and I'm i get this pawn him yeah this is
the night doesn't have fun any good the
only other good square halfway good
square would be queen would be three but
there's a look at this dis care both are
angry and just tronic in the chat is
asking if he play maybe seven it takes
the two pieces for the rug is it any
good probably not because two pieces for
the rough usually favors the side with
two cases and also in this case he would
be down upon for these for the for the
two pieces as well
problem is here also that sometimes this
kind of exchanges an idea if if I
thought a man it's not done upon but it
sometimes this can be an idea if white
has great activity for his rooks he's
got one rook for the two pieces and if
this rook is very active and doing some
concrete damage then this kind of
material imbalance can be an idea the
issue here is only the rook on a one is
doing nothing and the one only three is
so you are not going anywhere you cannot
even go to d3 which would be an idea to
sort of pin the night but why doesn't
have a decent move in this position
let's say we have a parliament that is
1234 I guess is watching the live feed
of the match the same Kremlin is looking
very frustrated and I guess that's
showing this is really not making any
move here yet it's maybe maybe he's some
sort of getting aware that this is just
nothing yeah and but then it's very
questionable what kind of preparation is
at work here because it's it's Queenie 6
is also I checked this in between us the
first choice of Houdini so it's not not
exactly a yeah revolutionary move I
don't know maybe he just didn't expect
the the semis laughs but well I'll just
for the sake of argument you know for
killing time here I know we didn't want
to use the engine but pedini is actually
giving me the line I see see takes d7
Brooke tasty seven and then be 34 white
yeah I was actually thinking about this
briefly I didn't think it would would
give much but the idea would be to to
sort of he accept that this pawn is is
also it's maybe a bit weak but also
annoying as it somehow hinders the rook
and this might win some time as black I
think would would capture area
yeah probably if it's giving giving seat
xp3 Queen takes be three fish would be
seven yep one Brooksie one rookie one
lucky one yellow yeah yeah this looks
like a pretty safe choice for work at
least at least I can hold the knight on
d5 here right yeah yeah I'm really what
what else but what is there in the
position for white to really play park
for a win yeah it's um I leave the only
thing all right here is Lou any chances
this looks quite quite equal to me of
course I would try to win as black
because I've got those 22 nice pointy
sticks here 57 on GSM but longer version
but of course it's not it's not so
clear-cut 35 not as strong of course but
it's that the problem here is a bit that
the pawn structure is completely
symmetrical and therefore it is it's
quite hard to ya to find any concrete
place or point of attack very often the
pawn structure being somewhat ya
non-symmetrical you have some natural
weaknesses somewhere you've got an extra
porn on one side where you like to push
the pawns and this is hard to see in
this position but this looks very safe
of course the 95 just blocks the center
completely and black is also not able to
do much it's got the two bishops fine
but they are not doing so much at the
moment and you cannot really play around
this knight on d5 there are some
instances where where you can actually
summer play around such a strong piece
and somehow sneak your pieces around
this piece but it's
to imagine you yeah and also to my eyes
the Queen was very precariously placed
on these open files like good day and I
can't imagine the Queen being able to
stay somewhere on these meetings e-file
or maintain detection of the night
forever just because of you know the
rook coming to the B file and
threatening discoveries that the other
river to go back to the age or something
like that it just seems seems dangerous
I never liked my I never liked having my
queen on any open file where my bad my
phone has a cigarette and if you
continue this line rook THM if you
continue this a bit black threatening
now again on d5 route III just covering
down term and here one very ambitious
Trius which someone here matches on the
chatter suggested is try to undermine
the night with f5 yeah this is idea this
is an idea we're thinking about this
okay it's not possible at the moment but
black can prepare this with some move
like this year King edge aid and then
try a five and if this f5 move is
working without a media why don't we
share these with why I five is that we
rolled our website version yeah this by
the first one this diagonal hora is it's
just the problem so this here the queen
is hanging on the eight so neither the
trappings of the Queen and while I leave
my bed well it would also pick up a row
yeah it depicts about everything wyd
wins wins the whole set of pieces here
but you can you can prepare this king a
jade analysis this is very ambitious but
ok this would be most probably my mafia
to try to get something going it's not
damaging anything I don't think or does
this blunder material in some way you
always have to be cautious because yeah
there's a lot of let's say energy on the
D file you need to check those
discoveries and so on and why does
also potentially a week on the back rank
am not sure king at JD says some some
trick here don't die don't see one at
the moment radio lc1 baby pain is bad
for cramming that you want so much time
already yeah we're thinking we're
thinking it's very strange as well I
can't imagine that this is good I think
I do we after the clock times I think it
would be we have got only ammonia
looking at the minor normal clocky and
it's it's four o'clock so the game is
running for about an hour and I don't
think uronian has spent any time ya know
or like challenges was not half of it we
so most likely from Nick is pretty much
down on the clock but maybe he's I'm not
sure hard to tell I'm not the 2800
player but maybe he's just trying to
find a safe way to to draw this position
at lecture yeah somehow trying to find
that is a final garden point here well
it's hard to play against two bishops
it's just just if you don't have
anything concretely for going for you
then it will be difficult let's say
let's say this position King h8 and now
let's say white plays some sort of
normal move I'm not sure not not good
but some some quite move and blacks
really Springs this f5 on you um yeah
this can easily get very ugly maybe it's
not working technically but okay does
the actually take these are valid way
all right very very reassuring that this
gum not something completely completely
crazy happening I just want to pull up
an old fritz quickly to check if this is
completely crazy now he gives gives
black some advantage so it's not
blundering a piece or something you
could
yeah oops okay so it's not not a piece
blunder or anything alright so let's
switch so again I guess so here we can
expect rotate visa yeah and then then
I'm curious what is what is doing I've
got in this position I've got lots of
arrows here but let's say oops I get
them together whoops hey funny little
bracket it should be easier to remove I
think you have the yeah you have to
really start at the where the arrows
starts and go all the way / okay no
ma'am I managed to get rid of all the
fun graphics yes someone is asking about
a recap of the game yeah we can do that
quickly it's not and not there's so many
moves played so chronic started with 93
is varying between nida 3 and d 4 just
often just leads to the same position we
got a Slav and now after 90 36 SMS love
kramnik now went for Bishop g5 which is
the sharpest move really as it allows
this pod Vinick line but of course
aronian I didn't didn't went for this
it's slightly suspicious this this line
so you went age six actually offering
white the chance to play Bishop h4 which
also would be a very sharp line but
Kramnik played the safe move with taking
on f6 then III which covers c4 and
Piazza developing of the bishop 97
Bishop d3 in this position instead of
Bishop d3 White has played
quite a lot of alternatives trying to
sort off winner tempo let's say a three
Roxy one but at the end we should be 3s
overstate the main move and now g6
cancels Bishop g7 rookie Mon castles a
45 yeah and we're getting close to the
game position white played d 5 years d4
was hanging rock d8 rook III b5 very
concrete approach takes takes bishop 95
and now queen e 6 which is the novelty
in the sun in this game and as Queen d6
has been played in a recent game the
final game of the European Championships
individual championships for women and
this was the decisive game for the title
very important game between the GU Nina
and moody choke where mother took went
26 takes takes and you can immediately
see the difference between queen e6 and
d6s now black's pieces are somewhat
clumsy on the default and he doesn't or
in this case she she she didn't get much
play against this night and this Bishop
a 92 here immediately attacked c4 and
she went protecting this piss porn and
in the the game aronian went for Queen
to e6 Kramnik took and now rock d 7 has
has already been played kisura yeah yeah
yeahs will be Devin hearing okay rook t7
and now you can see that this kind of
set up in a way measure makes them much
more sense as Bishop e7 puts pressure on
the d5 night instead of passively
offending the sea for porn just compare
this position black was sort of
defending this pawn sitting sitting
there rather passive with the bishop
this one and here rue 57 Bishop d7 will
be much more more active in comparison o
Kings pressure joining us in the jet
hello King pressure is there hi you know
I don't see it is my check lacking
legging anyway by the way maybe mine is
the newest chat in there for me so says
hi just explain your house EE okay yes
so route d7 let's see what most from
nick is coming up with and some yeah
well i think it's the kind of audition I
think this is probably where he spent a
lot of time in the last the last thing
tank you want to do they're just trying
to figure something out here so I guess
we'll see what he came up with because
white really has to do something there
or else you know there's really happened
in a position to try to fight at
berlin's so I look included we come to
ya say it always feels good to me if
someone is thinking long in a position
where you basically just have one move
and and trying to figure out what is
happening later because it always feels
to me like some sort of game where you
don't don't win anything because you
never know what your opponent might do
maybe he will spend some time as well I
don't know it's of course in this
position rookie 7 is very logically
plated immediately okay but sometimes
you are amazed how much time people
spend in completely simple positions and
it just makes sense sometimes to play
your only move and let the other guys
clock run down well we gotta move
ramekin Queen eight more yeah we didn't
have this one yet young yeah we didn't
think all of us yeah okay but it's a
fairly fairly logical of course as well
yeah Bishop Bishop sorry Bishop e7
seems very very normal here yeah and
then what about Queen takes d4 yeah this
section position we we had before
briefly about us yeah yeah why a queen
Queen c2 I just pull up the line we had
on Queen see to it takes and this was
this kind of line where I I was some
skeptical if white is even equal here
yeah you were thinking that after that
or FIV for young black yeah this is at
least equal god I would say this is a
significantly better for black for viber
to just be quiet yep maybe just maybe
just ok white had chances to create an
outside pass on but the bishop is just a
monster yeah especially combined with
the center f-5e for so this this won't
be it won't be the idea i think or maybe
so maybe white needs to do something
else in this position it's not exactly
am that I'm seeing anything right here
so that we think we're ruling out
anything after Queen take the war now
not not entirely maybe but we can we can
check again let's let's check this
quickly I take here this obsession
remove takes here of course why term
doesn't necessarily need to trade now
but what else is there
well what's safer let's say for
argument's sake he wants to keep Queens
on the blood where should we go now the
problem is simply let's let's say queen
a4 yeah just just to put it on the body
doesn't matter really because any green
move this bed actually so play you for
oh sorry this is this is not possible
okay maybe for wrong yeah when it were
like white almost died down on it the
back right we'll do that ya think i'm
thinking what what black wood planer
maybe just struck c8 grabbing the C file
also we've got the default already so
once you fun also what about something
like rook da threatening Eve or and then
background ideas alright it's no made
really but what what first this one
might is this snare not not this one I
would thinking briefly about about this
move this is may be possible the idea
being that this might win a pawn at the
end I'm not made here I've got you want
covered with the Queen so this would be
an extra porn yeah okay it's it's still
nothing for white rook c2 but yeah
you're just you're just fighting against
the the better minor piece here with
white so it's it's difficult maybe this
is not the best even maybe Bionic like
we thank me more you take time it'll be
seven eating equal you took yen okay
yeah it's it's it's just what can you do
I guess I guess the rapid claws will
come into play but or maybe a very quite
possibly yeah it's possible
well so we're expecting that we're
expecting out it should take Steve I've
but actually what about rook c8 Rudy hoc
it yeah yo it can we yeah it's a very
valid point just winning a temple here
more or less well why should I go now
don't have I don't have a great square
really really I like that oops yeah I
can join then I just just rub it I have
an extra tempo here yeah it's just like
to talk about your Obama's leave are ya
black ass black is better yeah no
question so wyd um yeah what needs to
find the clearer way to draw here maybe
let's let's let's say let's say tanki
takes here and rookie one preventing you
for this way or at least um this
wouldn't wouldn't be a huge problem i
can take here and I'm attacking e5 maybe
this is stable enough yeah this should
be a piece of it oh alright you should
still be to be okay I just the pawn
structure being put is magical run it
would be the provision versus behind but
there are not for really the vision
video method vision if you get an f5
before then it's a very nice you pretty
much dominate them all right vol it says
in do the same in my my chat here the
Chechen let
no such channel so it's gentle some oak
down or something what is so nice LT the
jab would I by the way Bishop takes d5
he takes the Bible's blood what is the
last thing you see in the church the
last thing I see is maybe what man is
1234 baby look CA and say h3 that let's
see five okay I'm refreshing know when
to side yeah I tested in here but in the
meantime we've kramnik decided to try
the paper but guess of when you hear you
play eat XD but instead of we take Steve
I versus what we were looking at what is
aria we had 38 5585 yup and ET val yeah
okay yeah skin so on Quincy for Aronian
topia he didn't play rook c8 yeah heat
up in PA uh-huh okay this interesting I
was really expecting this move it's just
the temple yeah look like just a temp oh
yeah Chester why didn't black bra and
rook c8 Queen check we're not we're not
sure what good us but anyway the
position on the board is 11 idea at
least could be of the immediate taking
it could be he takes d5 and I was always
taking with the Queen one idea could be
to take with the rook and in this
position the Queen on c4 which is still
on c4 and not after Luke c8 on some
other square I would again protecting
and then rook do you want maybe yeah
could could be an idea does not do a 4
wherein the Queen we're in Queen and it
was pretty clear that we have to move
somewhere and is aware mmm is it clear
well maybe it was very lean a long as
with
he was the real earthy one yeah I owe
you could also um you could also maybe
play a move like this here it's not
completely ridiculous but like rookie
one but it's not the red moon fire I
agree this could be an idea because the
rock on d5 is not badly placed it covers
also e5 from the side yeah and maybe
something like windy six or something
and then f5 yeah kingscrusher suggest
rootkit a one yeah sure this is possible
yeah or what about the other day he won
here this doubling on the car but it's
something good these devon takes the
yetis okay so he's like Queen tasty but
it's just a me okay he went for this I
need to quickly i'm sort of tidy up my
movie on that I still have the actual
game position so this this position
which we already had on the bought 40
minutes ago actually occur again yeah we
were looking at this a while ago yeah of
course memek spent a lot of time
thinking for those of you who are just
joining us and I'm not sure how many of
you been just joining us but this cram
except strangely a lot of time thinking
in a position that looks pretty obvious
and for a while yeah probably half an
hour 40 minutes ago christoph and i were
looking at this this particular its
exact position so now turned up and I
guess we'll see what preeminent has in
mind I guess maybe neither side is only
black has any chances to play for a win
here but it looks pretty draw or pretty
even I guess that was our eventual
conclusion
I would sort of expect now maybe why
taking brooke a one and this way of
threatening only five and now yeah what
should black do be five or singing the
cheap the cheetah way would be the cheap
way would be for and and immediate term
how I fishing about to do yeah this is
the simplest way and even that
okay I'm just thinking is this equal us
the better for black but maybe this is
equal White has some brew kforce maybe
some active move we black a somewhat
threatening rugae 5 a-2 and so on the
bishop is a bit annoying but ok white
will draw this yeah nothing the
technique of that already I so maybe
black should just cover your five maybe
yeah run run yay yeah rook e8 is very
yeah it's possible but yeah you don't
want your roof sir defend all the time
more like well that is yam maybe have
six little bit ugly yeah a bit of a pea
yeah you can try to to activate this
piece one thing though but there's a lot
that auditory oopsy one yeah don't take
this this will be effective ready I
guess if I guess if aronia just wants to
play no rift chess and and just filter
the drama mediately something that we
guarantee you will never ever ever lose
then this line with efore looks like
this it makes most sense to me yeah this
is just the super safe option you know
okay but i think this this kind of
positions here I would at least I
disputed people maybe not would need a
bit of time to figure out if there's
actually something to play for for one
side or not because it's a bit yeah it's
not so so completely easy because white
of course has this 22 world this one so
we can potentially and get a passport at
some time but very often this is just
yeah this is just something you read in
a book but never experienced in the real
game of chess very often this doesn't
mean anything anything other half on
yes very often is this three against two
on the queenside two against one very
often it just isn't so yeah it's not so
important if there are other factors for
instant in this position if black can
play Bishop f8 Bishop c5 or somehow
useless bishop how do you advance your
pawns with completely idiotic piece on
f3 this this night is just doing nothing
it's doing nothing it's it's also going
nowhere this this night is just stupid
so this is much more important than
those two against one and also note that
the black is somewhat quicker in getting
his King involved here this is often an
advantage of moving the F porn that you
get your king it took you play quicker
white would need some more time to to
get his King into something so okay I'm
five minutes to because of the chat is
mentioning that we need you is the play
I don't be that might be that i'm
watching on the game but we could take a
look at possibilities there i guess i'm
gonna be spent to try to drum up
something here I've know these inc
misheard pollen tears that are my queen
to it but three two okay yeah but this
isn't isn't a bad idea you can you can
think about this the only thing what
what bothers me a bit is d 5 is not
exactly a bed square for the Queen and
you have you somehow want to get rid of
this queen it just looks a bit too
beautiful to to let it to stay there
it's very long as the thing there with
the current power factor is also tied
down but they run a little bit here the
case crushers as H for here I'm not sure
k see whether that mean you want to want
to play h4 and come up some other day
after a queen Queenie to in this Queenie
to position now he's a type of work when
you do so maybe I'm not sure looking in
the the endgame
not that short but okay so nothing has
come through on the board that I had
good just just for those of you who are
curious pure is giving slight advantage
or for black in my friends position
minus 30 points free something else yeah
well off your point 37 mm yeah this
looks this sound so pretty yeah pretty
understandable sometimes you have no
idea what the computer actually wants to
tell you but this is just a little bit
better for black it's not only the
potentially better minor piece but also
the extra central pawn yeah this is
often really a misconception a
misconception that quite a lot of
players have that this majority on the
queenside is an automatic advantage
usually what you would you pay for this
majority of the queenside is a
disadvantage in the center you usually
have one central porn less than your
opponent and very often the center is
yeah quite as important as aspect of the
game so very often this is out penance
often this kind of 3 to 2 or two to one
majority is only a real factor if there
are some other things going for you it's
like if you control let's say the D file
in some position Y and you have got a
nice control of the open file and you've
got on top this advantage of 3 to 2 or
something then very often this is some
sort of additional advantage that can
help you press something else home but
on its own it it's not an advantage
usually that can help you that wins you
the game outright or something so
interesting don't with a noob chess
books they'll tell you that outside part
or outside majorities are always good
yeah they're they're hardly usually they
don't hurt yeah but it's not it not so
great there are some sometimes I see
people telling ya i've got three two one
and i'm very good here and so on and
basically it's just nothing you're
better we have some food to display
either drag queens rotate by 65 and 85
and rupee one rookie want and rug yay
yeah yeah very logical so this is so
moving out rookie idea rookie it yeah
yeah okay this was the move you this was
the move you suggested right and I just
said I don't want to protect passively
but ok the idea is of course or maybe
the idea is really f-5e form so it's not
a passive move maybe yeah I guess you
could buy prep Island before it was yeah
if you if you if you get this in and
don't get punished immediately in
whatever way I'm not seeing it but if
you don't have any particular problems
then you will be very fine is there any
way for white to try to draw up
something against the a pod Brigade
bringing some back all right just a
second I need to some of change this
here rookie 80 look a 3 guess
yeah one issue is you would like to play
before immediately well worth but but
but you cannot take here because the asn
the eight is hanging so maybe this is a
bit premature to advance advance the
pawn but you maybe you can just just go
here and use some the rook on the
fifth-ranked ear to to cover this and
then it's I don't know questionable if
you accomplished anything with this rook
looking for the repair or a more just
try I'm just trying anything to draw a
thumb pressure or right here usage as
this one I have to suggesting I maneuver
relieve our anymore yeah but it can i
could give this check here at least this
but but let's say let's say nano notice
this is some maybe even even stronger f5
and you get made it so after f5 you just
need to return to you one yeah this is
this smells like disaster really yeah so
I think what cannot cannot be
centralized this rope here he needs to
think about something else maybe I'm
chef well those of you who aren't aware
yet if this game does agree to be a
quick draw then they will play a rapid
game following she doesn't count towards
the official match score but should be
fun we'll take a look at as well I'm
cuckoo clue it's actually good idea I
don't know if the boos are coming any
faster on that site and on the side that
i'm watching but i'll see what's doin
okay my idea for coming up with anything
was departing it has over it yeah
someone is looking someone suggested g4
and that was just saying that this is an
idea 22 I wasn't I wasn't too sure
because it's somewhat weakening of
course but this really fights against me
I could play yeah it has been played it
has been played someone added on a shed
so g4g all right yeah I what I wasn't
sure if I was thinking about this but I
thought okay what if i go f5 anyway
let's say here and what what's your idea
now one idea of course in general it's a
it's somehow yeah Rob's black of some
dynamism here this exchange but I'm not
sure about the concrete ideas silly for
threatening so I was thinking knowledge
about my date or yeah not a trial but
i'm not sure if it is doing something
here really if i go here for now this is
not really well positioned yeah i'm not
i'm not sure but there's a gay bar it's
a biology far away yeah maybe maybe male
also at some point not here maybe f3 to
further attack the pawns yeah it could
be an idea and from the f5s of course
the critical move here black doesn't
need to do it immediately why doesn't
isn't really threatening something so
black could also try to move something
like a five on or similar visit some
slight strengthening move maybe but ah
that's an interesting suggestion not to
take on f5 yeah this is a good idea at
least a fits
so worth looking at attacking both f5
and g6 this way on marriage oriya it
might add my transpose but i'm not sure
i was just thinking maybe black can go
if I anyway but of course g6 the same
and dumb what I don't see you therefore
I can take it or do you mean in this
position effort I got my power on the
part of the army but yeah this this
isn't really desirable I can block now
and drop the knife up and you you're
trying to somehow dead in your bishop
here I'll kill you I flip it worthwhile
all right yeah if you could come to you
for this is not easy for the night to to
get there but yeah this is not a move
from legatee ones to play on my phone
back up very well is black oh yeah now
Nottage for here is so it's an
interesting num an interesting try but
yeah it needs needs further analysis
also black might consider silly hoops to
take here though takes here and then
trying to make use of the fact that this
night is a bit stranded here it detects
the fire but let's say you you're just
attack it and I think why dumb white
will most likely due to H form you could
could go here I was thinking rock d tau
a rube t2 then yeah complicated yes
welcome here yeah but that it sure looks
like a good idea I think it's maybe the
better move in comparison to to taking
and
nie Dage form so yeah interesting but
the question is so if black really wants
to immediately go at five boy if he if
he goes for thumbs something else what
about a scheme where he delays at five
maybe prepares it Wow the problem is
about all the pressure on the g5 upon
can you can't he doesn't have any peace
freedom but I was thinking something
like roof to f8 f5 maneuvering the
bishop around to the a7 g1 diagonal and
maybe some pressure on f7f too but I
guess he doesn't really have the freedom
of the peace movement because they're
all tied down too yeah you know this was
the red leaf I right now wait quite
upset yeah this was he played f6 yeah
why didn't he play if 6 like I told him
before now that this is what I was I was
just trying to explain this was this was
why I suggested f6 here in this position
yeah bro nian we were found you about
the half an hour ago and just a joke but
this was the idea why I suggested f6
it's looking ugly but it it protects a 5
yeah very reliably so you can move your
other pieces yum okay but it's it pretty
much came to a similar position so he
went out F five but f6 here of course
the difference is he played here if six
only after white went g4 this is quite
some difference of course but it's a
similar structure at least we're
inviting fight at left-back mean I hope
I didn't someone say f 6 plate no no I
don't think though I don't see it hadn't
come about be the website okay so maybe
we are talking nonsense here but I don't
think it's such a bad move really but
not sure but
of course you need to calculate f5 it's
the most active possibility but this is
probably probably not there now on the
feed I have coming up King age 7 been
played and I can see the clock time also
on this website so running has an hour
22 minutes remaining kramnik is 53
minutes remaining and the mood was keen
age 74 lat okay interesting yeah this is
maybe I'm due to the idea of f 59 h4
does the government Yvonne yeah yet to
cover g 6 cm that night h4 is in the
temple right now and ever and ever and
now I ch4 so what's it suggested the
idea being aged 5 yeah I think this is a
it's an interesting try sometimes you
can try to too yeah sort of play in a
way to get squares for your night you
need two squares for for this piece and
this is trying to to get to get squares
each foils the idea of maybe going going
h5 and just for argument's sake h 4 a 5
h 5 something like this maybe they then
you would have some idea of getting an
ID to to the square one even sometimes
let's say something like this here this
also might be an idea i did this kind of
position you managed to ya prevent f64
for quite a while and then you can try
to get your night also to e4 without
having to worry about the F on moving
due to the N personal capture so this
kind of structure can also be a
beneficial for whites because you've got
this efore stronghold for the night so
yeah I think with the night on you or we
why would have chances to do
yeah jazz and susan too bad so this move
h4 is something to consider the only
thing is some you need to do some
calculation f5 again as now night h4 is
definitely not possible but but h5 maybe
is something to look at which why i can
just take them but yeah I can just
retake and I've got an extra porn it's
nothing nothing great coming up here we
are and on f5 if you need to to capture
now then this age for move was quite
terrible just a weakness yeah you don't
have knowledge for any more and possibly
this this pawn can get really weak like
Bishop f 634 it's gone yeah the Sun can
be quickly backfiring on white so maybe
f5 maybe you can think of g5 but now you
force a very nice pawn chain and once
the rock on the edge is moved then this
night will be post a very serious
question where would where would you go
please and it doesn't really have
anything to go to some have any outpost
oh I don't adopting offense but I don't
think really don't think a h4 sir so
it's a good move
maybe one what g51 need to just g fiber
yeah ok this is the same positional idea
that i mentioned before I've black goes
who are hiring a tri-d or no no you you
happy for us a potential out post-mortem
or upon days yeah i was i was just
wondering what happens if i take here
was a living this kind of stuff I for a
job but isn't this just good for black
or is there some concrete um technical
issue this just about some revenge three
yeah but this this isn't going anywhere
about burning right no no way you don't
have you don't have many exciting taking
chances here you are both first of a
barber yeah is you you don't have
anything and taking wise hmm i'm not
quite sure what what's the exact point
here only thing i can well need is the
line g5 85 85 check gata-3 Luke a three
yeah okay so pick not trying to pick up
cape on and and it gives will be seven
and let run equality spike bench for
black hmm yeah it's playable the problem
is about Fisher page six nice to go or
fight each for worse than I thought yeah
it still doesn't have any any good term
positions to go to and just from a
positional strategic point of view this
action here yeah led to white having
three Pawn islands yeah Black has just
two so what do you bring about the test
birthday upon the our kids well peace is
also important like activity but and
when i meant i mention this thing about
outside majority is three to two and so
on I'm not rewriting chest Theory here
you just need to pick up a modern middle
game book and it just tells you the same
thing it's not that I'm telling
something that no one else is agreeing
with us and thing then you only need to
look at the modern book and not some
some 100 year old stuff yeah it is yeah
it's a huge difference it's huge
difference well even though kramnik has
this big thing I think in a position
like this you would you say 45 minutes
is enough whether this phone when I'm
drawing idea yeah sure I don't think why
does in a huge danger already as it it
is just the kind of position where maybe
I'm yeah sort of sort of i would feel
somewhat uncomfortable in this position
because you cannot do much why it has
very few active possibilities but if you
yeah really invest a bit of time and
find the correct way to set up your
pieces it's very likely that kramnik
would draw this I mean this is the best
technical player maybe shoshoni of the
current top players and I'm not quite
sure about overall history but he's
certainly not far away from being the
best so I've got a thing yeah what other
hand is a technical position sure yeah
slightly slightly of course is not those
guys know how to play there take
physicians but if you give kramnik the
sort of slide something then is